welcome to the first cloud lapse episode
on the gcpd central quest on quick labs
creating a virtual machine in this quest
you get your first hands-on experience
with google cloud get comfortable with
the basics like spinning up a VM and
configuring key infrastructure tools
through working with more advanced
stacked driver and cuber Nettie's
concepts you will work your way through
each lab on quick laps until you have
completed your quest and receive your
badge you do not need a Google cloud
platform account or project an account
project and associated resources are
provided to you as part of each lab
let's see what this lab is about then
Google compute engine lets you create
virtual machines running different
operating systems including multiple
flavors of Linux Debian Ubuntu Red Hat
and core OS and windows server on Google
infrastructure you can run thousands of
virtual CPUs on a system that has been
designed to be fast and to offer strong
consistency of performance in this
hands-on lab you'll learn how to create
virtual machine instance using the
Google cloud platform console and using
the G cloud command line create a
virtual machine with the g-cloud command
line deploy a web server and connect it
to a virtual machine it's helpful if you
have familiarity with standard Linux
text editors such as vim Emacs or Nano
Google compute engine is the foundation
to Google cloud platforms infrastructure
as a service next up on our quest is
compute engine QuickStart windows a
quest is a series of related labs that
form a learning path on quick laps
completing this quest earns you this
badge to recognize your achievement good
luck and have fun
[Music]